and we're gonna begin with this a
manhunt is under way in Canada after an
American woman and her Australian
boyfriend were found dead Chyna Dees and
Lucas Fowler were on a road trip in
northern British Columbia Police in
Fowler's native Australia say it appears
they were both shot Nicky batiste is
following the story Nicky what a
terrible terrible story the details are
haunting what do we know Tony it is
terrible good morning well Canadian
police aren't saying how exactly the
couple died but they are investigating
these deaths as homicides they are
asking anyone with information or
dashcam footage from a remote highway
way that where they were found to come
forward meanwhile DC's family is calling
her death devastating
she was really adventurous really
outgoing Stetson DS describes his 24
year old sister China as a free spirit
who travelled the world often times with
her boyfriend
Lucas Fowler they were both extremely
nice both very optimistic and also
spontaneous the couple was road tripping
in northern British Columbia their
bodies were found last Monday by their
van on a highway near the liard hot
springs a popular tourist destination
it's not yet clear whether Lucas and
China were targeted or if this was an
opportunity a crime of opportunity
Curtis and Sandra Bratton say they met
decent Fowler shortly before their
deaths
the Bratton's pulled over to help the
couple with their broken-down van and
left when it appeared they knew how to
fix it we were there to help them but
yet that same day the complete opposite
of humanity hurt them like that and
killed them so tragically the deaths
happened near the so called highway of
tears 48 hours has previously reported
on that notorious remote stretch of road
where at least 18 women in the last 40
years have disappeared or been found
murdered at this point we have nothing
to indicate that their deaths are linked
to any other active and ongoing
investigations
Stetson D says he always felt his sister
was safe traveling especially well with
Fowler
he believes the couple was going to get
engaged soon it's like a nightmare that
will never wake up from
Fowler's father is a police officer in
Australia and he and other officers are
now in Canada
DC's brother told us her passport was
found in the van but it appears the
couple's other IDs may be missing and
this is just a horrific case so bizarre
the highway of tears they call it
eighteen women yes and at the moment
it's a hundreds of miles long but they
out to other teams may be missing and
another body was found about four
hundred miles away but this highway is
notorious connected they're saying they
don't know yet if they're connected it's
got to be worse to know that you lose a
loved one this way but it's got to be
even worse not to know why how what
could have possibly happened to them the
family alone
the family has lots of questions yes as
we all do Thank You Nikki